As we've seen so far, motion can be
a powerful tool to direct attention, and
provide cues about how something works.
But as all [LAUGH] Spiderman fans know,
with great power comes
great responsibility.
Motion needs to be used purposefully and
judiciously.
Here are some practical tips for
designing motion that enhances the
experience, rather than detract from it.
>> Let's start off with some basics.
How long should your animations run for?
Here's some examples.
The first one here is too slow.
The animation feels gratuitous.
The second one is too fast.
It feels almost accidental.
The third is just right.
Animations should be slow enough
to convey their meaning, but
as fast possible, so that they don't
get in the way and become annoying.
A good rule of thumb is to use
animations that are around 300ms long.
And tweak from there if they
feel too slow or too fast.
Remember that in general, designers and
developers alike, tend to use animations
that are longer than users would prefer.
So if you think you need
one full second for
an animation, you probably actually
need a lot less to get the point across.
And another tip, where possible,
use the size of the object and
the distance it needs to move,
to help you time the animation.
This will make sure that animations
that can have varying start and
stop states,
feel right in every situation.
Now that we know how long
animation should run for,
let's talk about interpolation.
In the real world, objects don't
start or stop moving instantaneously,
like in this red circle.
They accelerate and decelerate
to get from point a to point b.
Now, material design takes
this a step further.
Motion curves in
material are asymmetric.
Meaning as objects move,
their acceleration and
deceleration aren't equal.
For objects that move across the screen,
you can use a fast-out,
slow-in transition.
Because most of the movement
happens early on,
items spend more of the transition
near their final position.
The effect is that animations
feel fast and precise.
This also reduces a lot of
the negative effect that
can come from too much motion.
And when elements are entering or
exiting the scene, do so
at full velocity.
For objects entering,
the linear-out slow-in
interpolator works well for this.
For objects exiting, you can use
the fast-out, linear-in interpolators.
Finally, let's talk about the notion
of user-initiated change.
This is really,
really important in material design.
Almost all state changes start
with something the user does.
User input, such as touch and
keyboard focus, is thus at the very
center of motion story material design.
Here's an example similar to
what we saw in lesson two.
Notice how the surfaces respond
to touch by lifting up and
showing temporary ink ripples.
Coordinating motion around the user's
touchpoint makes complex state changes
easier to visually process and
understand.
In this example, when transitioning
between two states, animations across
the screen are staggered based on
their distance from the touch point.
The result is that the motion feels
more intentional and connected to you.
It makes you feel powerful and
in control.